gotta talk about twitter because you are
you are i mean look
you have what you've got over a million
followers yes
yeah which so you can't argue with
success
yes i i mean if you call it success it's
certainly
yeah it's people follow me and that's
good it's not for any
purpose i do have to remind people it's
not called
social change or heavy debate it's
called twitter
the clue is in the name but then
occasionally it can be a great force
like the protests about the elections in
iran or the john moore absolutely
about gately twitter came into his own
it seemed that's that's absolutely right
um and it it it has revealed a power and
a
uh and a sort of force and that nobody
could ever have predicted even six
months ago i didn't think so are you
more careful or more thoughtful about
the things you put on twitter now
because
the papers do pick up what you say they
do and i yeah i i had a bit of a wobble
a few weeks ago and i got i got rather
disenchanted with the whole thing i mean
i i love
i love the twinternet as you might call
it now i love the the the online world
you know the
the set of manners that goes with being
online is one that suits me for some
reason it doesn't
others but it does me but there is a
downside it literally
is the downside if you look at someone's
blog or you look at a youtube film or
something like that
it's filled with comments it's for
people who have decided
to be unarterably mean and utterly
resentful and angry and bitter
and insulting and rude i'm sorry about
that i'm so sorry
[Applause]
that is the um that is the unwanted dead
caterpillar in the otherwise lovely
salad
internet but even while you've been in
the building you've been tweeting
i i did yes because i've been following
your tweets oh my goodness yeah i
tweeted about your very nice goody bag
did you give us guests
you've got to pick me if i look at you
i've got a dream twitter page up here oh
my goodness
that's you just click the link the top
link that one
wow it looks like a hessian
sack yes so and so you've got
what's this goodie bag
oh that's sad a lot of it is hair
product bill
and the ones that aren't hair products
are
okay shaving products fine you know i
just like to know where to stand
my mother my mother was asking who's on
the show and i said stephen frazier all
right
and uh i said bill bailey and she went
oh is that the bald man with the long
hair
which seems like a contradiction
but it's true it's true and yet yes
in reviews i get that i got this great
view it was in the independent said
bill baby he looks his hair hangs down
his back like a shower curtain
and his head remember there was a large
egg
this isn't a review this is like
biological field notes
you can often
[Laughter]
because uh obviously we know who's going
to be in
uh our so we've been following something
how many of you twitter just uh
oh wow please that's quite a few uh now
uh where
is uh lobster linguine who's that
lopsid linguini hello what's your real
name james
james would have been awful if he said
lobster
why why do you ask no reason
now i have to say lobster to greenie
james
funny they are people people are great
um oh no i like that no actually i say i
retyped the post due to a grammatical
error
on a side note i have a conundrum i have
the jumbie jambay
oh you've got african drums at six
tomorrow and tickets to graham norton
oh no
he missed you missed your gembi he
missed the african drumming for
this but then this is i think this is a
good joke
if a hob is a male ferret then what's in
hobnobs i dread to think
it was it was based on a um mark watson
was on
mastermind and he got the question wrong
on hob so it was kind of a reply to that
but i thought it's a bit yeah
tweet about that
[Applause]
that's what it's good yeah that's right
who else do i have um where's
underdog 100
oh hello hello now what
i don't know what goes on in your mind
it it just seems to like
this it's like things just bouncing
around quite fast
so this is what's been happening in a
trade card right uh is going to watch
the graham norton show tomorrow should
be a laugh
30 days till christmas looks like a
lovely day what is today going to have a
store
it's going to try and make a casserole
this should be fun
i think that's all turned out okay i'll
be still alive
eating too many jelly tarts having nancy
mendes today
how much earning do i freaking have i
ain't gonna rate why have they changed
pringles
[Applause]
my kind of twitterer how random it is
eating jelly chocolate
massive sugar rush
she's wearing a mitten she i think that
might be attached to her junk
oh no no just a long sleeve sweet about
that
john and edward go now uh james b
and dizzy amazing did a little tear come
out with robin the boys reunited i was
in floods brillo pads
and then uh this was to you she said
that she used to
teach are you on craigslist this week
i'm watching me phil i will win my seat
if you're there
she answered it will be a good week a
good week
has a little bit come out
i want to start a new uh shorthand on
twitter you know there's
lol you know and uh in my humble opinion
imho
fml pmso and all this rofl rolling on
the floor laughing
i wanna have a new one which is
r-o-f-l-y-s
which is rolling on the floor laughing
yet somehow still typing
you